[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ستواصل إيطاليا دورها كشريك
يمكن الاعتماد عليها مع التحالف
Atlantica بدءًا من الدعم إلى
شعب أوكرانيا الشجاع المعارضين
لغزو الاتحاد الروسي
[موسيقى]
كثيرًا لأننا لا نستطيع قبول
حرب العدوان والتعدي
من وحدة أراضي أ
دولة ذات سيادة ولكن أيضا لأن الطريق
الأفضل للدفاع عن مصالحنا
صفقاتها التجارية ولكن أيضًا
لتوريد المواد الخام
من سياسات هجرة الطاقة إلى
تتغير الخيارات الجغرافية لمحاربة القاعدة
الإرهاب تحديات كبيرة تواجه
التي ليست دائما لي
[موسيقى]
واحد الأوروبي
الذي يعتقد أنه من الممكن تداول
حرية أوكرانيا مع بلدنا
راحة البال للاستسلام لابتزاز بوتين
على الطاقة لن يحل
ستزداد المشكلة سوءًا عن طريق فتح ملف
مزيد من المطالبات الطريق مع Enrica
الزيادات المستقبلية في الطاقة حتى الآن
أعظم من الذين
لقد عرفنا في الأشهر الأخيرة
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الاتحاد الأوروبي موطن لنا
مشترك بين الشعوب الأوروبية وعلى هذا النحو
يجب أن تكون قادرة على التعامل مع
تحديات كبيرة في عصرنا أ
بدءا من تلك الدول الأعضاء
هم بالكاد يستطيعون التعامل بمفردهم
[موسيقى]